steve is with us in california hi Steve
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey David just discover to you last week
thanks taking my call on earth how can I
help so I'm a warrior a couple years out
of law school and I just got a new job
at a big law firm making about two
hundred thousand dollars a year
wonderful yeah so I've got about eighty
eight K in debt but after having
listened to you for a week I I know I'll
know no problem paying that off real
quick this year good my question for you
is I know this job isn't very
sustainable I work like 80 plus hours a
week lots of stress and I don't
particularly enjoy the work but I'm good
at it I want to eventually leave and
become a government prosecutor but
that'll be a huge pay cut so I kind of
wanted to get your advice on how long I
should stay in my current high paying
job to kind of set myself up for
financial success and frankly to
capitalize on you know the years of
school and that that I've been in so
you're on the standard meat-grinder one
two years I just grew a lawyer thing and
if you if you survived the meat grinder
you might become one of the 47 partners
right right I don't see that happen for
me just based on my interests but you
know I get huge raises every year he's
gonna seize every year so it seems like
I'd be throwing money away to leave you
know without spending some time in this
job but kind of wondering how long that
needs to be well I mean mathematically a
long time physically emotionally and
spiritually not long at all right and
that's what you're saying that's the
juxtaposition or the paradox you're
facing so I certainly want to stay there
long enough to get that 88 grand go home
right and you've just gotten a job right
right so what would be your ideal game
plan I'm thinking I'm thinking two years
I could I could definitely do but I'm
just trying to think like yeah I know if
you take the job as a prosecutor so in
the prosecutor's office you make what
probably 80 80 K year 80 80 200 so more
than cut in half yeah yeah and it
i maxed out at like 120 yeah I mean the
kind of weird position of my income
peaking early in my career rather than
later well with that job but not rotten
not it not in other forms of law mm-hmm
at that you know that your career
nuanced choice within the law is causing
that not the law sure because I mean you
could stay on the other track and
actually step back from the 80 hours go
open your own boutique firm and make
three or four hundred ten years from now
depending on the area of practice you're
in and so forth what city you're in in
California all those kinds of things so
that all of those things are possible so
what's the lure of the prosecutor's
office it's worth $100,000 a year kinda
what I've always wanted to do but after
going through law school I did I did
well enough to get this high paying job
so I kind of listened to my professors
and they said you know you gotta go do
this that's not the question to question
okay the question is what is so fun
about being a prosecutor that it's worth
you paying a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year for the privilege
dropping probably slightly better
quality of life but also just kind of
what my passion was going through school
I like the criminal law aspect of it I
like the justice aspect of it and you
can't do that on the defense attorney
side is your passion huh I could get the
criminal law experience when the defense
attorney sighs but not necessarily the
kind of calling towards doing justice in
my mind yeah okay
well I just I really I mean I appreciate
that and I appreciate the nobility of
the call that's on you I don't have a
problem with any of that but what you're
asking me and I'm just trying to reframe
your question back to you to give you
some ways of thinking about it and I'll
give you an example and this borrowed
borrowed future podcast we're talking
about them meeting the
morning that we're doing on student
loans that's out there and is real
popular right now seth godin said you
can spend two hundred thousand dollars
to go to college or you could spend ten
thousand dollars and go to Community
College and have one hundred ninety
thousand in your pocket to open a
business with mm-hmm
and that's kind of how I'm trying to
frame this up I'm using that kind of
mindset to say okay yeah yeah you're
going to get down from but there's more
than two options in this scenario that's
fatalism we know there's more than two
options more than 80 hours a week and
you grind up into meat and there's
nothing left of your life you have no
marriage you have no future you have no
relationships all you are is a worn out
lawyer making 253 years four years from
now you don't want to do that I'm with
you on that I got no problem with that I
wouldn't wanna do that either right
that's I'm scared the only other option
is not a pay cut in half and the only
place to get justice is not in the
prosecutor's office and so start
thinking about you know that's why I
asked about defense as an example I
don't know if I'm in your shoes though
I'm gonna start thinking of ways I can
have high quality of life which is 40 to
60 hours a week and I can make 250
trending towards 350 with my law degree
in California and tickle the justice
bone right and I'm just gonna start
thinking about that and I'm gonna start
asking around you got two years to work
on this problem because you're gonna
stay there for two years anyway right so
go talk to some of the prosecutors go
talk to some of the defense people find
people that are of high moral quality
and noble character that are in the law
they're there there's they're not all
over the place but they're there and sit
down and talk to them and say this is
what's happening go talk to a judge go
talk to a federal judge ask him if you
can have coffee because judgeships don't
just come out of the prosecutor's office
if two friends are pointed in the
judgeships this year both of them came
out of private practice right so I'm in
that you gotta tickles the justice
funnybone about as much as anything does
sure sure
so in federal judgeships pretty good gig
so anyway the the I'm just thinking
through this with you
you
got to figure out a way that to say
don't get trapped in the the nuanced
thinking that there's two options
anytime somebody presents me two options
and neither one of them sound fun I
always say see not a or B see none of
the above start again
take the SA version of the test just do
the multiple choice version and let's
dig down into this in the next two years
and let's find out what your options are
I think you can find something that'll
do all that if you want to be a
prosecutor I'm not mad at you but I
don't want you to make a hundred and
twenty thousand to two hundred thousand
dollar-a-year decision based solely on
this improper view that that's the only
way to create justice in the land is
from that office that would not be true